hello I'm Kim goth cruise university
secretary and vice president for student
life here at Yale I'm pleased to share
with you a conversation between Yale
professor mark Brackett and an author
and media commentator jo-ann Lippmann
about the power of emotional
intelligence to change our lives this
conversation is a special program of
Yale well an initiative that is designed
to instill mindfulness and wellness in
our student body
dr. Brackett is a former mentee of Yale
president Peter salivate and he has
studied the science of emotions for
twenty years he is a family director of
the Center for emotional intelligence
and of course a wonderful colleague in
the Yale well family his book permission
to feel unlocking the power of emotions
to help our kids ourselves and our
society thrive was published this fall
miss Lippmann is the best-selling author
of what she said what men need to know
and when they need to tell them about
working together until 2017 miss
Lippmann was the chief content officer
for Gannett and editor-in-chief of USA
Today and the USA Today Network she
serves on the Yale Daily News board the
Yale School of Music advisory board and
until recently she was a member of the
University Council although these talks
often focus on the student experience
today's talk really focuses on something
that's important to all of us and I hope
you enjoy this conversation as well as
the questions of the audience asked you
actually had I want to talk about Yale
students for a moment because you
actually had and I have to reference
this in the in the book you you
mentioned trying to understand what Yale
students are thinking and you talked
about you asked several hundred Yale
students about stress and really found
that underlying it was something very
very different where they talked about
stress it was actually something very
different yeah
again I think even you know our Yale
students you know high academic scores
but you know no emotion education
so just like everybody says happy as the
positive word everybody in the world now
when you ask them you know I stressed
I'm stressed and then I had them do some
writing about their stressors and what I
learned was that a majority of that
stress was really envy and to me that
was super important to know and I'll get
to that at a moment but what I found was
that so much of what our students are
doing is making social comparisons
throughout the day they're sitting in
class making this one's father is a
famous politician they're gonna have a
free ride
this one's parent is really wealthy
they're not gonna have to worry about
anything this one is the real
valedictorian I'm like the fake
valedictorian and then they're on social
media five to six hours a day looking at
people who are doctoring up their photos
and they're just in constant you know
dissonance you know in terms of itself
from the portrayed self or from other
people and so then when I got them to
realize that a lot of them are feeling
Envy I believe that was the pathway
towards helping them regulate and I've
had some you know challenges with even
colleagues here because people are
thinking about one-shot ways it regulate
everybody's doing yoga I'm like I love
yoga too and people we do breathing
exercise them I like to breathe too but
you can't like the breath and yoga can't
be the answers for all of our feelings
and if you're living you know I always
think if I'm breathing Wow even it's
even clear to me why I'm so envious so
we've got to teach people strategies on
how to reduce those social comparisons
and have a different kind of self-talk
so the idea is to get rid of envy the
idea is to reduce the causes of the it's
to understand the causes and to use that
Envy wisely so you know I'm very
fortunate I get funded by a lot of
wealthy people and I go to their homes
and I'm like you know and the end of you
can either be resentment or I can be
grateful right for having them support
the work or it's
you know what maybe I need to work
harder so I can have that kind of home
or something like that or I need to
challenge myself in terms of my thinking
about it and saying you know because for
example myself coming to Yale
I had a I grew up in a more blue collar
setting you know and getting here was a
way you know a different world for me
and I could just spend my entire life
thinking wow that thought that person's
father read Shakespeare to them like my
father didn't even know what Shakespeare
was or I can say or you know have a more
positive self-talk and say you know what
look at me Here I am and you know not
everybody has to have the same
experience to be successful so let's get
to another Yale question because another
Yale student question which I thought
was also really interesting and maybe we
can bring in the audience on this one
because you asked students to share how
they hoped they would feel at college
and also got a really interesting
response or we'll have to ask that
audience
what nothing sure and any just any
guesses just shout it out how do you
think students yale students answered
the question how would you hope to feel
at college anyone challenge inspired
confident fulfilled creative so what
blew my mind was they said loved so when
I asked them you know how do you want to
feel as a student the word was loved and
I was taken aback by that I just was not
expecting it and then when I of course
you know given that I teach these course
I'm like time to write an essay
you know what's love got to do with it
and
essentially what I found was that many
of them feel like they had been
manufactured sadly enough you know many
many students said you know my parents
made me do this and I had a rote I had
to write an essay about this and I had
to travel to this foreign country where
no one had ever stood you know step foot
before and I played instruments that no
one ever heard of before and they felt
like they really had lost their identity
but also many students said they just
felt like they didn't have they had a
more transactional relationship with
their parent and they just were really
just wanting to be loved so how do you
respond to that I mean what's the what's
the next step once you understand that
you write a book and then you get it to
all the parents
[Laughter]
seriously though because this is the
issue we face and it's that you know
unfortunately in our nation schools and
workplaces right adults have not had an
education and emotion and so they're not
aware of the things that they're
modeling the ineffective strategy that
they're modeling they're not labeling
their feelings accurately they're not
aware of what they're saying is and how
its influencing how kids feel and hence
why my vision is to have an education
and emotion from preschool
you know until till the end of time so
and you do have a framework for that
which we should mention and some of you
are probably familiar with it because I
do think it's kind of gotten out there
in the world which is ruler correct
which perhaps you want to just kind of
briefly tell us what ruler is sure I
think what's important to know about our
work is that the first stage is really
what we've been talking about which is
do I believe in my you know heart that
emotions matter do I really believe that
how people feel matters and if you
mindset issue the second is all right so
what are the skills and we're very
blessed that emotional intelligence was
coined here at Yale with Peter and his
colleague Jack Mayer who was my doctoral
adviser and over the years we've refined
the theory and the skill
now we have an acronym that we use ruler
to describe the first is recognizing
emotions in oneself and others picking
up on like how am I feeling
what's my body telling me what's my mind
saying what am i appraising in the
environment around me
the second is understanding emotion so
for example anxiety is about uncertainty
fear is about danger I just won when I
was going up for tenure
I was completely stressed out like I had
heartburn I went to the doctor and my
doctor said you know here's your
prilosec and here's your ativan look
wait a minute there has got to be a
better way and what I realized even from
my own own self was that I was not
labeling my own emotions correctly I was
going in saying I was stressed and the
truth was I really wasn't stressed I was
overwhelmed and until I labeled my
experiences being overwhelmed like
having too much on my plate and not
having any breathing space
I wasn't regulating it properly I wasn't
leaving work at a certain time to get my
exercise in I wasn't giving myself the
space that I needed so that's the the
third skill which is labeling so we say
the first three skills of recognizing
understanding and labeling are the
skills that help us build awareness of
our own and other people's feelings like
what am I feeling and you got to pick up
on the body the mind the cause and then
label it the last two skills the Ely are
are what we do with our feelings
expressing them regulating them so
expressing emotion has to do with
knowing how and when to express your
feelings with different people in
different contexts including culture and
then we are the last star is regulating
which is the big one
at the top of the emotional intelligence
hierarchy is regulating which is the
strategies that I use to manage my own
feelings but also the strategies that I
can help in Co regulating other people's
feelings
to the labeling cuz I do think if you
don't label it correctly you're never
gonna be able to get to b2b expressing
and regulating it correctly and it does
seem like labeling seems to be a
sticking point for a lot of people for
parents for students yeah is there a way
to sort of more accurately understand
what our own emotions are so that we can
label them yeah so maybe we can we have
a slide if we can jump to the next slide
if possible it should be a tool that
we've built my colleague David Caruso's
and I have built what's called the mood
meter and essentially that the mood
meter is at the heart of our of my book
and essentially every moment of our day
we are making appraisals like you walk
into a room like that it's like I'm
looking at all of your facial
expressions right now and I'm a little
worried like more seriously right you're
you're you're looking at people and
you're saying are they feeling
comfortable are they feeling
uncomfortable when you walk in to give a
presentation like what it what am I
feeling in my body right now do I feel
overwhelmed do I feel comfortable do I
feel like I want to approach - oh no
avoid we also look at our energy levels
like our activation levels is what do I
feel like I can thrive in this space or
do I feel completely depleted
that's the pleasantness and the energy
on the mood meter and then when we put
those two things together we get these
four quadrants the yellow the red the
blue the green and essentially you know
the goal of our work is first to take
the complexity of your inner life and
just project it out into a motion space
am i only yellow feeling high-energy and
pleasant am i on the green feeling
pleasant but low and Andreo mind around
the blue meaning unpleasant with high or
low energy then I say all right why well
I'm about to be on stage or whatever it
might be so what might be the feeling
associated with that oh I'm nervous
or I'm excited and that's a process that
in the beginning is quite slow but once
you get trained in our work it becomes
you know automated be amazed you go to a
third-grader they're like I'm feeling
I'm not feeling happy Sarah I'm feeling
ecstatic or I'm not feeling calm I'm
feeling tranquil
and sometimes peaceful it's amazing how
specific they get it takes all of that
complexity right like and it just says
all right what's my body I'm my body's
high in energy all right am i pleasant
or my unpleasant unpleasant oh I'm in
the yellow so then why am I in the
yellow oh because I'm on stage talking
about my work that's exciting it's just
that simple process and you have to give
people the words they have to learn the
words and that's obviously what I teach
and if you don't have the four quadrants
with you and by the way some schools now
right they actually put the chart up
there so students come in and they say
this is where I'm feeling I'm in the red
today so yes ruler is the name of the
approach to teaching emotional
intelligence or what's broadly called
social and emotional learning we're in
2,000 schools across the United States
200 here in Connecticut 350 in New York
City and all over you go into a ruler
school and there is a mood meter
everywhere because people are using this
as a way to build self awareness as a
way to build their vocabulary and
importantly as a way to help them manage
their feelings there's a question that I
know you get a lot but I want to put it
out there because I think probably
everyone in this audience whether you're
a parent or student you have heard this
which is we are living in a world full
of young snowflakes right that they they
can't take stress and they can't take
you know for those of us who are older
you know we were we were much more
resilient right and and they should be -
right that's the that's their the
criticism that you often will hear how
do you respond to that well firstly I
think if these are the if these who
you're talking about are the children of
those adults like what did you do to
create the skids right so I think that
we have to realize that we are
co-creating this world that everybody is
living in so that's just a really
important piece I think to put out there
the second is that like emotions are
emotions their feelings you can't judge
them they just
exist so we have to get at the root
cause of these feelings like if everyone
is anxious it's time to look at it give
you an example we know from statistics
that suicide rates have gone up by 28
percent over the last 20 years that's
that's something to make fun of that's
something to say wait a minute we need
to take a step back and what is the
world that we have created for our
children to grow up in anxiety about 25
percent of our nation's adolescents have
an anxiety disorder depression is the
leading cause of disability worldwide so
Timmy goes back to what I said earlier
is that these feelings are information
and is it about raising you know
children who are weak well I don't think
so maybe it's that we have not had the
adequate emotion education of the adults
raising these children and we haven't
taught children the strategies on how to
make them have art to support them but
secondly I just want to give you an
example of a student here who is you
know I had difficulty with this student
and she was a little arrogant with me
about best things it was nine o'clock on
a Sunday night and I got an email saying
professor Brackett I just can't take the
test I'm overwhelmed I'm stressed I'm
having a breakdown and I need you to get
back to me ASAP I was like whoa like all
good professors I ignored the email I
figure it's nine o'clock at night on
Sunday like I get some time to write
anyhow
my point to this story was that in the
end when we I did many little mini
interventions with this young woman and
what I found out was that her mother
lost her mother when she was a freshman
in college and that her mother is
putting enormous pressure on her and
instilling all these fears and her
mother's visiting every weekend and once
they got from dinner every weekend and
to me that's a demonstration of a parent
who has not been adequately trained in
emotional intelligence you
this mom is literally instilling the
fear and anxiety and her daughter so I
believe it is a responsibility of adults
to provide an adequate emotional
education to kids and it's not just the
emotion education I think which really
was revelatory because that convicted me
counted that in the book and I thought
was really revelatory was that I think
for most professors or adults if you're
the boss and you get something a note
like that it just you would say what an
entitled young I won't use the word that
I thought right and would write off that
person but what you did was very
different which was you instead sort of
dove in and just started asking gentle
questions about what was going on in her
life correct because you don't really
know someone to tell you another story
and so I needed to get at the root of
her behavior and of her you know stress
levels and once I learned what it was my
you know feelings of anger from her and
you know being entitled went to empathy
and compassion right I this this young
woman really needs supports to manage
her emotions and manage her mom
otherwise you know she's are gonna have
that constant pressure and once you
understood that about her how does that
help her because they gave her the
awareness of where her feelings were
coming from and then that's an action
plan now she's got to figure out how to
manage the relationship with her mother
better just that's a reality that she
has to face and she needs support in
doing so there was a similar story that
you tell about yourself when you were I
guess about a teenager and you were you
you you you failed a martial arts yeah
test and I thought that one was also
really quite revelatory about how we
approach other people's emotion and
maybe you could talk a little bit about
that one yeah so when I was going
through my struggles as a kid
one thing that my father thought to make
me a tough guy as you can see it worked
really well was to go into the martial
arts and I happen to be a martial arts
instructor and have a 5th degree black
belt now but I was not like a kid that
you would think would go into martial
arts anyhow I was like a precocious kid
I want I wanted to have power I wanted
to be tough and I wanted to get my
yellow belt so I like push my sensei
you know like let me take the test let
me take this head let me see it
finally he's like alright take the test
lo and behold I found the freaking
yellow belt test so a variety of things
right happened in that moment the one
that was the most painful to me was when
I was putting on my street clothes one
of the kids in the locker room said
something like we know you're gonna fail
the test you loser wait you see what
it's like for you on the way to school
tomorrow that's a big deal for a 13 year
old and knowing that I really couldn't
communicate how I was feeling which was
fear and shame to my parents what did I
do
I went home I hate you I'm never going
to karate again and that activated my
mom and my dad my mother get together oh
wait till your father gets home can't
wait for that to happen dad comes home
right I can't believe you're talking
about that way again if I have to tell
you one more time and so essentially I
ended up getting punished and no one
knew how I felt and then I had to get up
in the morning go to school so this is
why so much of this work again is about
adults a managing their own triggers so
I triggered my mom right she got
overwhelmed and my father got angry they
didn't have the strategies to deactivate
they didn't they weren't emotions
scientist who knew and I asked these
delicate questions to find out what was
really going on and so what happens is
that a kid like me suffers unfortunately
and so an alternate in an alternate
scenario had your mother instead of
lashing out when you came in and said I
hate you I hate this I'm never going
back instead of lashing out at you said
it's you know tell me like what happened
like let's talk about this right is that
dependent like timing is everything with
these things so if I can't hate you
now it's not like ten what have I time
gonna happen cuz that's like you know
that's not gonna work
you've got to both be in a place where
you can become so you can have the
conversation so it's being you know
clever around you know what honey you
know let's go for a walk or you want to
go drink of water or maybe you know why
don't you go take some time and watch TV
in your room or whatever it might be it
it just helped me deactivate also as a
parent I might need strategies like I
might need the space to like because I'm
triggered by my kid being so mean and
cruel and all the things that are going
on my head about that so I need space
too
the big issue here is that often times
when we build the space we forget to
reconnect and actually do the problem
solving oh now he's fine let's move on
truth is the bullying is gonna happen
again
the fear and the shame are still there
so at what point do you come together
and then have that rich conversation but
I think what's important is that the
adult has read this kind of information
because if my mom doesn't really
understand how to ask the questions and
doesn't herself have the language to
understand the difference between fear
and anxiety and shame and all these
other emotions then the stories that I'm
sharing are not going to come together
in a way that would help her support me
in the best possible way I want to go
back to also in this story it was your
dad who wanted you to toughen you up and
that really raised questions for me my
work is a lot of my work right now is
focused on gender and how gender
interplay and gender differences and
that gender gap in the particularly in
the workplace and I'm wondering if you
see a gender gap in the way that we
interpret emotion or experience emotion
so a few things about gender and emotion
there's one and then in it I'm going
traditional binary here for a moment
there is one gender that says they have
higher emotional intelligence than the
other gender and then there's that other
gender that actually has higher
emotional intelligence so I'll let you
all figure that out
but as you might imagine like men think
they're higher in emotional intelligence
and women of a woman actually score
about a half a standard deviation higher
on average than men so that's just I
just like add that that men also
overestimate their IQ by 15% of women
underestimate theirs by the same amount
so anyway yeah but I think what you're
getting at here is early stereotypes
that are kind of just put into our
brains you know that boys don't cry and
you know girls shouldn't be angry
because the boys will be weak and the
girls will be labeled X Y or Z and we
grow up with those mindsets and those
belief systems and then you know
influence how we interact as adults and
we know that there are differences with
regard to power in the workplace so the
person of the most power can feel
whatever they want to feel my best
example is actually in the workplace I
did a talk for a big financial company
in New York City and the chief executive
he said to me you know like interesting
stuff mark but like there's one thing
that I'm clear about I don't really need
this training I was like wait
and then I interviewed a person who
worked for him a high-level executive a
woman and she said to me you know I was
she was in the meeting and she said it's
interesting because a couple months ago
we were talking about emotional
intelligence and he literally said to me
it doesn't matter how you feel no one
really cares because the only thing that
matters is that you represent me so you
can interpret that how you like to me
it's a power issue it's a gender issue
and an equity issue and it needs to be
dealt with do you have some tips for how
to deal with that I think people need
again I'm going back to my treatise
people need an emotional education that
we have to recognize that everyone
deserves the right to have the
permission to feel and I think what's
most interesting about this CEO is that
he's so naive about the role of emotion
in the workplace so I don't know about
you but has anyone here ever worked in
an environment where you woke up in the
morning and you thought I actually
cannot stand the person I work for and I
feel disrespected and undervalued
does anyone ever have that experience
you can raise your hand it's okay
and when you have that feeling when you
wake up in the morning how many of you
save yourself like today's gonna be the
best day of my life at work right you're
just like oh can I get a sick day I oh
my ankle hurts you know you'll do
anything to avoid work because literally
you're predicting you know how you're
gonna feel and if you think you're gonna
feel disrespected and you know
unappreciated you're not gonna give your
best and actually we did a big study
this year with 15,000 people across the
workplace workforce and what we found
was that the emotional intelligence of
supervisors actually was highly
correlated with how people felt with
their intentions to leave their job with
their burnout rates with their
creativity so I think that our CEOs and
managers are naive if they don't think
that how people feel matters so I agree
a hundred thousand percent with this
actually when I talk about gender issues
in the workplace I always say it's got
to start with a CEO because they need to
understand that they're the ones who
change the culture it's not they're the
ones who create and can transform the
culture and you mention that about the
workplace you mentioned this about
parents about teachers but let's talk
about if you're not that person right
you have someone who's not emotionally
intelligent who is the parent or the
boss and you are the student or the
child what strategies can you suggest to
help those people deal with that
situation you know it's funny I was a
couple months ago I was in a parking lot
with a mom who was like a lunatic you
know with her kid and I just saw what
was happening and I was like do I
approach the
you know hi I'm the director of the
Center for emotions I really wanted to
and then I thought but like I just
listened to this whole dialogue as they
were going in to the store and I thought
to myself what can I do to support this
kid and truthfully I was thinking of
writing it out like run away now because
I couldn't imagine you know like having
that craziness every single day you know
stop doing it stop doing it you know and
so I really think that it's gonna take
some time in our nation to get the
adults to understand these things
putting that aside children deserve to
be supported that's just the way it is
like you can't tell a five-year-old
here's an example I was in a school
recently and the teacher said well I
just leave my feelings at the door it's
like I'm not sure that's really possible
another teacher here in Connecticut said
well I'm just gonna you know this is not
really a training for me so I'm just
gonna stare at the clock all day I was
like are you kidding me
so now to imagine now a real experience
I was in New York City a preschooler I
was in a preschool he came into school
hysterical crying and what I learned
from the school psychologist was that
what's that boy experienced that morning
was the following parents are going
through a divorce the father went into
the son's room and said your mommy loves
someone else and you're gonna have a
different daddy that was the reality of
this four-year-old he's being dropped
off at school by the nanny and all of a
sudden now am I supposed to tell this
little four-year-old like put your
feelings in a box outside the door you
know stare at the clock all day so well
the parents in the situation you know
are doing harm in my opinion the good
news is the brain is plastic it is you
know it can be you know developed
through other caring adults and why we
spend so much of our work in schools
right because if we can train teachers
on how to do this work and have a mood
meter and have other tools to support
children and learning the words and
developing the strategies
feel like they have a caring and loving
adult at least it will help a little bit
until we get to all those parents so let
me give you a situation this may or may
not be hypothetical and it may or may
not have happened to me with a one of my
children so what do you do if a child
has and I'd like this from both sides a
child not a four-year-old but you know
like a teenager or a college student
it's just had just a just a dreadful day
just a really horrible day and they come
back they're totally stressed and they
want to scream and yell and talk about
it and they do want to talk about it but
they're there they are kind of
hysterical in venting about it and the
parent is the parent
you're not you're trying to calm them
right so now this is I think is probably
very common other people right so what's
how does that both the the parent and
the child regulate themselves so that
they recognize what the emotions are and
so that it doesn't escalate yeah well
one of the things that we have in our
Center is a tool that we call the meta
moment and it's one of our you know
besides the mood meter the meta moment
is a tool to help you build the space
between that trigger and that typical
kind of ineffective or unhelpful
response and in that space what we say
is you have to do a number of things one
is you've got it just doesn't matter if
you know how you feel like you may be
just completely overwhelmed you got a
pause and you got to take that breath
because if you're highly activated nor
chemicals like cortisol get released
which make it very hard to problem-solve
and hard to think and hard to ask the
right questions
so we've got to figure out a way to
deactivate the second which is a really
cool piece of our work is seeing your
best self so if I were to ask you right
now I'm putting you on the spot as a mom
my best self has these qualities what
would those qualities be and you don't
have to answer right now I'll give you
time to think about it but all of us
could do that right as a husband as a
wife as a partner as a mom dad like my
best self has these qualities and maybe
you would say things like loving
caring compassionate and what we find is
that when you pause and think about Oh
Joanne is the loving empathic
compassionate person
what happens that you start supporting
your child through that lens of those
emotion terms and it's quite helpful so
for him for me like whenever I get I'm
easily triggered and activated sometimes
you know a student here actually when I
first took my class they labeled me the
feelings master and it was you know at
first I was like a little barren I was
like you know what I am the freakin
feelings master so when I'm activated by
a particular student and I'm like the
true self is like you entitled whatever
and I went wait a minute
how are the feelings master respond and
you can see all of a sudden all the
anger that's directed at the person who
triggered me is now redirected back to
my best self as the feelings master
feelings master would be a wizard with
this child they'd make this into a
project does that resonate what about it
what if it's the student or the child
same thing applies everyone can have
their best selves so they need to think
about their best self also everybody
needs to think about their best selves
there's another strategy and I do want
to leave time for Q&A here but there was
another strategy that you mentioned in
the book that I thought was pretty
revelatory which was self talk yep
and particularly using your name your
name can you can you explain that yeah
well one thing about self talk that I
think is so important let me just ask
the audience for a moment does anyone
here ever say negative things to
themselves about themselves yeah I mean
like unfortunately for all of us I think
we are programmed from early childhood
to be meaningful to ourselves I will
argue that often comes from the adults
who are raising us in our peers so if
you're overweight or if you're too tall
or your nose is too big or if you're a
different color like people start making
fun of you and saying cruel things to
you without proper intervention you
start believing it and then it becomes
your self-talk
I think how much time we have spent in
Our Lives rehearsing all the things that
we hate about ourselves or don't like
about ourselves and how little time we
spend challenging those thoughts and
shifting them to more positive talk so
the trick for positive self-talk is
distancing what that means specifically
is oftentimes when you're in that
negative view you're very self-focused
and it's hard to get out of it so
instead of saying get over this you say
something like mark you can do this and
for me because I have the tendency to be
overwhelmed go figure and ruminate often
times before I go to bed I can testifies
things like if I'm eating doesn't go
well Mike they're never gonna do our
program it's over and then I'm take my
breath and I'm like mark you're making
this story up like you're just making
this up and literally by doing that it
tell it takes all the feeling and it
kind of distances the feeling from the
self and it allows me to just deactivate
but I love the concept also of putting
your own name in which I never would
have thought of but but it's very
interesting it's like putting yourself
in the third person exactly yes exactly
which is really interesting because in
my work with gender I will often talk
with women who are afraid to raise their
hand for a promotion or a reason I will
always say to them think of yourself in
the third person if you were in the
third person how would you describe that
person and it's much easier to do that
cuz much easier to advocate for somebody
else and so it is so you put yourself in
the third person and advocate for
yourself well and interestingly so one
is that self talk which is Mark take the
high road mark you're making this up
very helpful to help you manage your
feelings or stop the rumination but
something else that's quite interesting
is that another way to do or have
positive self-talk is to just think
about how you would support a close
friend or a loved one so if you heard
something negative that happened like
you failed the test the karate test
right what would you say to yourself I
don't know well if you find out your
best friend fail the karate test
what would you say Oh
okay we're gonna work together we're
gonna get through this I'm gonna
practice with you
like you'd have all these great
strategies to offer your friend that you
don't offer yourself so maybe take a
moment and just think about how you
would talk to a friend about this and
then apply those same principles to
yourself fantastic are there any other
because I do want to leave room for
questions is there any other strategies
that you want to briefly mention before
we go to question I mean I think that
the big ones in terms of the cognitive
ones to help us manage our feelings are
the self-talk strategy the other one I
just mentioned is what we call positive
reappraisal it's just can you tell
yourself a different story and it really
is remarkably helpful to just say wait a
minute
there's got to be another way to look at
this and just it's a creative process
that actually gives you that space to
help you manage that feeling okay we
have time for some questions and we have
two folks with microphones
I see questions over here and over here
one over here one over there hello
feelings master my name is Devin I'm a
graduate student here and I'm asking
about when you look more deeply into how
Yale students were feeling stressed I
wonder why you ascribed envy to it which
i think is a more active word you know
people are envious as opposed to you
know self-doubt or insecure which is
more of a passive feeling how did you
pick envy over insecurity because again
it's about understanding the nuance of
what feelings are about so for example
jealousy we always play around with in
my book and then our work we talk about
jealousy and envy some people confuse
those two a lot
jealousy is a relationship driven
emotion right someone looks at your
significant other and your significant
other that gives them a little twinkle
right you're feeling jealous you know
that you may lose your significance to
that person
envious is really wanting when someone
else has and what I found in my research
here is that a lot of our students
unfortunately are just making these
endless social comparisons they're
wanting you know if only I had a father
who was a
politician so I can get the job in DC if
only my parent were a zillionaire then I
would have to worry about as an only
this so it's that social comparison that
really helps us understand that its
enemy hi MA and I just was wondering if
you could maybe elaborate on you talked
about that situation with the CEO who
kind of felt like emotional intelligence
was just not something that he needed in
his life as an emotionally intelligent
person how do you encourage people who
are a bit cynical about this whole
concept to maybe think that there is
some benefit to their life you know
that's why you know we have a center
here called the Center for emotional
intelligence and we do research to make
the claims because honestly you know
nobody really cares about mark
Brackett's opinion I mean I'm glad that
people are interested in me and what I
do but this is evidence-based right the
science shows that leaders who are
higher and lower in emotional
intelligence create different workplaces
and CEOs and managers don't know that
information they don't know that
emotions drive how people attend to
things they don't understand that
emotions affect the decision-making
process that they affect relationships
and mental health and creativity and I
think once people really understand it
and it's no longer the professor's
opinion but it's hard fact we're gonna
get people you know to to get on our bus
I thank you for your talk I love the
idea of thinking through the lens of
your best self but is there a danger of
over-regulating oh this is how I should
behave so yeah the danger of that it's a
great it's a really important thing to
distinguish which is and my colleague
Robin who's not here today would talk
about this in terms of being gaslighted
right well you start changing your
behavior to acquiesce that's you know
you have to be a scientist around your
strategies so if your reappraisal czar
let's say you're in a relationship and
someone says you know you're kind of
sensitive and you don't really believe
you are but then you start reappraising
saying well maybe I am too sensitive
that's being the self saboteur right
you're not really objectively looking at
the situation saying actually I'm not
too sensitive like you're being you're
not being kind so with all of our work
it's not just about using the strategy
you have to evaluate those strategies to
make sure that they're actually helpful
to you and and supporting you in terms
of dealing with your feelings
effectively hello thank you my name is
Chris really enjoyed the talk and
looking forward to reading the book so
my question I have two questions
first question is what safeguards do you
imagine implementing to prevent this
from turning into a therapy let's say
you're trying to help others in this
type of way of thinking this structure
this framework is there how much
training is required to make sure that
you're doing this correctly and are
there safeguards from coming construed
as therapy that's the first question the
second question is you mentioned a few
times there in the talk about how you
were kind of predisposed to certain
emotions I wonder is that a tribute to
of certain personalities that do you
believe that personality is also kind of
on top of this this grid and some people
are predisposed certain aspects of the
grid thank you
sure I'll answer the second question
first which is yes there there is a
relationship between emotion and person
so if you take our mood meter tool the
two factors that that would be looking
at are things like emotional stability
and extraversion and introversion and
but the point I think is this is a
language issue and I cover this also on
my book which is that I'm a neurotic
individual I worry about everything I
worry about why worry
I even worry about why I worry about why
I worry and like I don't really have
that much to worry about but
nevertheless that's like my default
thank you whoever up there and thank you
mom and dad and for years I thought my
personality was my emotional
intelligence and I realized it's
completely different one is your
proclivity towards experiencing strong
emotions and what emotional intelligence
is is what you do with those feelings
now yes given that my personality is
more neurotic I may have a greater
tendency on a daily basis to experience
you know fear or anxiety or worry but I
really think it's critically important
for people to recognize that personality
does not drive or is it's not even
correlated with emotional intelligence
like you have to learn the skills if I
heard you're it's hard to hear up here
actually but your first question was
about when do you teach this and how do
you differentiate it from therapy yeah
if I had it my way we would start in the
womb just to be truthful truth you know
it's like let's start people as early as
possible and that because what we know
from research is that how parents feel
during the process of pregnancy actually
it does influence the fetus that's why
we need to make sure parents have these
skills and understand them our work in
schools begins in preschool kind of
language where language can take place
so we start with three-year-olds and we
go all the way up until high school and
now in collaboration with Kim and our
Dean we're looking at offering these
tools and strategies to our
undergraduate population obviously the
workplace I think what's really
important to know about emotional
intelligence that's very different from
cognitive intelligence
is that you know most of our lives in
academia have a criterion of correctness
you know you have to get the the a means
you got the answer correct meaning three
plus three equals six or whatever
calculation with emotions it doesn't
work that way there's no correct feeling
and there's no correct strategy
it's what strategy works for me given my
background given my gender given my
culture to support me and having greater
well-being better relationships and
whatever goals and dreams I have for
myself and so that means that as
educators we have to be scientists that
are helping children explore and
practice strategies to find which one's
work best for them and then you know
refine those over time and sometimes
they'll work and then you say there's a
gosh my positive self-talk didn't work
today
well maybe you need to call a friend or
maybe you need a break or maybe you need
to just go to the movies so there's a
lot more flexibility with emotion
regulation and a lot more exploration
that needs to take place
hi thank you so much for this talk I
really enjoyed it I think the part that
I found most striking that you mentioned
which just totally like surprised me was
the fact that Yale students said that
they hope to feel loved and that was the
number one desire out of Community
College and in a place where so much of
our self-worth is based on our accolades
and it seems like it's worth with
qualification and so many things
required for acceptance what do you
think needs to change for that envy to
kind of be for an antidote to envy yeah
I think that's a whole other
presentation that we do here but I think
briefly is we need to train people early
on you know about what envy is and you
know the deleterious effects of having
that for too long that's one piece of it
but also it's what we value we have to
shift a little bit of our values in our
culture and that's something that is
beyond you know emotional intelligence
really that's really taking it a step
back and saying you know what are the
values of this institution what are the
values you know in our society right now
that are creating you know this enemy
that are creating this stress this
overwhelm and one of the things that I
say in our in our work is that we are so
focused on the individual like
self-control and having perseverance and
we don't focus enough on the classrooms
on the families on the institution's and
when we think about what does it mean to
create an emotionally intelligent
institution right maybe that will change
the way parents talk to their kids about
what it means to be successful and in
turn you know we'll have less enemy
I think there was a question back there
following up on that short of changing
the world what kinds of strategies have
you come up with for addressing this
tendency towards in vain I didn't hear
that last piece the tendency towards
tendency towards envy what kind of
strategies towards what I think you know
most of it is that self talk you know if
you catch yourself constantly saying to
yourself something like I'm never gonna
be a successful that person and that
person is gonna you know have more
opportunities than I am
you've got to monitor yourself talk and
say wait a minute how is that supporting
me and having well-being how is that
supporting me in achieving my goals so
again a lot of it is just monitoring the
things that you're saying to yourself
trying to find sometimes if you can like
where does that come from and then just
really practicing you know greater self
compassion and shifting that negative
talk to more positive talk and it's
effortful and it just is something that
we have to spend more time doing and we
know from research that it makes a
difference one of the things that I
gleaned from reading your book actually
was about it's related to self-talk but
it is about appreciation of what you
actually have the things that you do
have the the fact that you maybe have
you know a terrific family children's
supports the story the things that you
do have that you know as opposed to
focusing on well that person has more
money but you know I have that's exactly
and you know there is also a rich
literature on gratitude right thinking
about one of the things that I'm
grateful for and so when you get lost
in your specific envy you may just take
a breath and step back and said about
wait a minute I'm grateful I'm a student
here I'm grateful that I get to have
this amazing education I'm grateful that
I have a loving brother and that's
another way to help support you and
experiencing more pleasant than
unpleasant feelings right up front here
thank you so just bending out the
question that you raised which is what
does it mean to create an emotionally
intelligent institution I'm curious to
know is there anything in the works at
Yale particularly for staff students and
faculty so that's a question for Kim
there you know we are working on this
and I feel blessed and I'm on the
yeah.well committee and we are thinking
continuously about how do we infuse
these principles you know into the
university I can tell you as a professor
of the medical school there is a
tremendous amount of interest both of
the hospital and among different
departments in training people and
doctors and new doctors in these skills
so I think that we are in a good place
to create what we like to call an
emotion revolution both in our society
and even here at Yale I think we see one
more question
oh the mic up if you don't mind oh I
think my questions are follow-ups on
some of the things you've just mentioned
first of all I want to tell you
something you'll be happy about given
the last statement and at a neighboring
University they've just started a
program for undergrads who are in
management reading president salaries
book on emotional intelligence and the
title of the course is mindful
leadership to become more aware of these
types of things to lead better in case
they didn't get it when they were
growing up but my question is really
this recently I made the mistake of
saying to someone young man who
obviously I didn't know well but I could
tell immediately had immense
mathematical ability and my question to
him well I didn't say I made
common and an educator was nearby and he
was very upset by my comment to the
child so I'd like to know how I should
have phrased it because this young man
had exceptional mathematical ability
exceptional and I said well you're going
to do well on the SATs and the educator
got very upset that I had said the wrong
thing that I was now setting up
expectations but instead what I was
trying to do was show that I could
recognize his ability and that he could
use this ability however he wanted so
what what would have been the correct
thing to say so I'm not gonna be like
you're you know the president tells you
the correct thing to say but what I will
tell you is that the way we phrase
things to children and our friends and
colleagues can have what you might call
a fixed mindset or a growth mindset a
fixed mindset way of saying thing is it
you're gonna be fine you know you're
perfect great job whereas when you
praise or when you give feedback that
rebut that focus is on learning goals as
opposed to performance goals oftentimes
people will work harder just try for
that so what I would say is that you
want to stay away from fix things like
you're gonna do great and say you know I
really am blown away by how much effort
you've put in to studying and practicing
for this and what we find is that that
makes a difference
so now you mentioned that the program
really starts with kids that are as
young as three years old but I'm
wondering are there any strategies for
kids that may be younger or for parents
of children that are younger than
through you souls things that we can do
or think about as our kids are growing
up yeah so when I said that we start
early doesn't mean that we only start
early ruler which is our evidence-based
approach to social-emotional learning is
a preschool to high school approach and
there are some schools that start in
high school and some districts as there
are in middle or elementary school you
can start anywhere because right this is
these are a set of skills that anybody
can learn at any age and that's
important to know so that's just
something critical what I want to also
say is that what we've learned over the
years just to go back to our way of
doing this work my uncle and I failed
pretty badly because we wanted to put a
program in a school and what we now
realize is that it's not about putting a
program into a school it's about
literally infusing the principles of
emotional intelligence and to the way
leaders lead the way teachers teach the
way students learn and the way parents
parent and so the question is as a
parent like what is your role and
responsibility to support your child's
healthy emotional development you know
and you know that's what I write about
in my book and that's what we have in
our families program approach for
schools
step one and maybe this can be our last
point which is you have to just be the
role model you've got to monitor as a
mom like what is your self-talk sound
like to your child
remember your kids are listening to you
your kids are watching you and they're
learning from you are you that role
model are you taking that breath are you
using that positive self-talk the second
is does your child believe that you have
given them the permission to feel do
they believe in their heart that you
really believe that all their feelings
are valuable and that you're not judging
them for being shameful or fearful rings
that anxious or whatever the case is and
then the third piece is do you work as
an emotion scientists you know with your
child do you help them really understand
their feelings their causes
do you validate those it's
and then you work with them to help them
think about solutions and they're gonna
try those strategies and some will work
some won't work and it doesn't mean
you're a loser or a failure when your
strategy doesn't work it just means you
either have to try it more or you need
to try a different one it's fine way to
end would you join me in thanking our
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]